I'd like to revisit a deceptively simple
question that I asked in the very first
video of this series
what are vectors is a 2-dimensional
vector for example fundamentally an
arrow on a flat plane that we can
describe with coordinates for
convenience or is it fundamentally that
pair of real numbers which is just
nicely visualized as an arrow on a flat
plane or are both of these just
manifestations of something deeper on
the one hand defining vectors as
primarily being a list of numbers feels
clear-cut and unambiguous it makes
things like four dimensional vectors or
100 dimensional vectors sound like real
concrete ideas that you can actually
work with when otherwise an idea like
four dimensions is just a vague
geometric notion that's difficult to
describe without waving your hands a bit
but on the other hand a common sensation
for those who actually work with linear
algebra especially as you get more
fluent with changing your basis is that
you're dealing with a space that exists
independently from the coordinates that
you give it and the coordinates are
actually somewhat arbitrary depending on
what you happen to choose as your basis
vectors core topics in linear algebra
like determinants and eigenvectors seem
indifferent to your choice of coordinate
systems the determinant tells you how
much of transformation scales areas and
eigenvectors are the ones that stay on
their own span during a transformation
but both of these properties are
inherently spatial and you can freely
change your coordinate system without
changing the underlying values of either
one
but if vectors are not fundamentally
lists of real numbers and if their
underlying essence is something more
spatial that just begs the question of
what mathematicians mean when they use a
word like space or spatial to build up
to where this is going
I'd actually like to spend the bulk of
this video talking about something which
is neither an arrow nor a list of
numbers but also has vector ish
qualities functions you see there's a
sense in which functions are actually
just another type of vector
in the same way that you can add two
vectors together there's also a sensible
notion for adding two functions F and G
to get a new function f plus G it's one
of those things where you kind of
already know what it's going to be but
actually phrasing it as a mouthful the
output of this new function at any given
input like negative four is the sum of
the outputs of F and G when you evaluate
them each at that same input negative
four or more generally the value of the
sum function at any given input X is the
sum of the values f of X plus G of X
this is pretty similar to adding vectors
coordinate by coordinate it's just that
there are in a sense infinitely many
coordinates to deal with
similarly there's a sensible notion for
scaling a function by a real number just
scale all of the outputs by that number
and again this is analogous to scaling a
vector coordinate by coordinate it just
feels like there's infinitely many
coordinates
now given that the only thing vectors
can really do is get added together or
scaled it feels like we should be able
to take the same useful constructs and
problem solving techniques of linear
algebra that were originally thought
about in the context of arrows in space
and apply them to functions as well for
example there is a perfectly reasonable
notion of a linear transformation for
functions something that takes in one
function and turns it into another
one familiar example comes from calculus
the derivative it's something which
transforms one function into another
function sometimes in this context
you'll hear these called operators
instead of transformations but the
meaning is the same
a natural question you might want to ask
is what it means for a transformation of
functions to be linear the formal
definition of linearity is relatively
abstract and symbolically driven
compared to the way that I first talked
about it in chapter three of this series
but the reward of abstractness is that
we'll get something general enough to
apply two functions as well as arrows
a transformation is linear if it
satisfies two properties commonly called
additive 'ti and scaling additive 'ti
means that if you add two vectors V and
W then apply a transformation to their
sum
you get the same result as if you added
the transformed versions of V and W
the scaling property is that when you
scale a vector V by some number then
apply the transformation
you get the same ultimate vector as if
you scaled the transformed version of V
by that same amount
the way you'll often hear this described
is that linear transformations preserve
the operations of vector addition and
scalar multiplication
the idea of grid lines remaining
parallel and evenly spaced that I've
talked about in past videos is really
just an illustration of what these two
properties mean in the specific case of
points in 2d space one of the most
important consequences of these
properties which makes matrix vector
multiplication possible is that a linear
transformation is completely described
by where it takes the basis vectors
since any vector can be expressed by
scaling and adding the basis vectors in
some way finding the transformed version
of a vector comes down to scaling and
adding the transformed versions of the
basis vectors in that same way
as you'll see in just a moment this is
as true for functions as it is for
arrows
for example calculus students are always
using the fact that the derivative is
additive and has the scaling property
even if they haven't heard it phrased
that way if you add two functions then
take the derivative it's the same as
first taking the derivative of each one
separately then adding the result
similarly if you scale a function then
take the derivative it's the same as
first taking the derivative then scaling
the result
to really drill in the parallel let's
see what it might look like to describe
the derivative with a matrix this will
be a little tricky since function spaces
have a tendency to be infinite
dimensional but I think this exercise is
actually quite satisfying let's limit
ourself to polynomials things like x
squared plus 3x plus 5 or 4x to the
seventh minus 5x squared each of the
polynomials in our space will only have
finitely many terms but the full space
is going to include polynomials with
arbitrarily large degree the first thing
we need to do is give coordinates to
this space which requires choosing a
basis since polynomials are already
written down as the sum of scaled powers
of the variable X it's pretty natural to
just choose pure powers of X as the
basis function in other words our first
basis function will be the constant
function be 0 of x equals 1 the second
basis function will be b1 of x equals x
then b2 of x equals x squared then b3 of
x equals x cubed and so on the role that
these basis functions serve will be
similar to the roles of I hat J hat and
k hat in the world of vectors as arrows
since our polynomials can have
arbitrarily large degree this set of
basis functions is infinite but that's
okay it just means that when we treat
our polynomials as vectors they're going
to have infinitely many coordinates a
polynomial like x squared plus 3x plus 5
for example would be described with the
coordinates 5 3 1 then infinitely many
zeros you'd read this as saying that
it's 5 times the first basis function
plus 3 times that second basis function
plus 1 times the third basis function
and then none of the other basis
functions should be added from that
point on
the polynomial 4x to the seventh minus
5x squared would have the coordinates 0
0 negative 5 0 0 0 0 4 then an infinite
string of zeros in general since every
individual polynomial has only finitely
many terms its coordinates will be some
finite string of numbers with an
infinite tail of zeros
in this coordinate system the derivative
is described with an infinite matrix
that's mostly full of zeros but which
has the positive integers counting down
on this offset diagonal I'll talk about
how you could find this matrix in just a
moment but the best way to get a feel
for it is to just watch it in action
take the coordinates representing the
polynomial X cubed plus 5x squared plus
4x plus 5 then put those coordinates on
the right of the matrix
the only term that contributes to the
first coordinate of the result is one
times four which means the constant term
and the result will be four
this corresponds to the fact that the
derivative of 4x is the constant for the
only term contributing to the second
coordinate of the matrix vector product
is two times five
which means the coefficient in front of
X in the derivative is 10 that one
corresponds to the derivative of 5x
squared similarly the third coordinate
in the matrix vector product comes down
to taking 3 times 1
this one corresponds to the derivative
of x cubed being 3x squared and after
that it'll be nothing but zeros
what makes this possible is that the
derivative is linear
and for those of you who like to pause
and ponder you could construct this
matrix by taking the derivative of each
basis function and putting the
coordinates of the results in each
column
you
so surprisingly matrix-vector
multiplication and taking a derivative
which at first seemed like completely
different animals are both just really
members of the same family in fact most
of the concepts I've talked about in
this series with respect to vectors as
arrows in space things like the dot
product or eigenvectors have direct
analogs in the world of functions though
sometimes they go by different names
things like inner product or
eigenfunction so back to the question of
what is a vector the point I want to
make here is that there are lots of
vector ish things in math as long as
you're dealing with a set of objects
where there's a reasonable notion of
scaling and adding whether that's a set
of arrows and space lists of numbers
functions or whatever other crazy thing
you choose to define all of the tools
developed in linear algebra regarding
vectors linear transformations and all
that stuff should be able to apply take
a moment to imagine yourself right now
as a mathematician developing the theory
of linear algebra you want all of the
definitions and discoveries of your work
to apply to all of the vectors things in
full generality not just to one specific
case these sets of vectors things like
arrows or lists of numbers or functions
are called vector spaces and what you as
the mathematician might want to do is
say hey everyone I don't want to have to
think about all the different types of
crazy vector spaces that you all might
come up with so what you do is establish
a list of rules the vector addition and
scaling have to abide by these rules are
called axioms and in the modern theory
of linear algebra there are eight axioms
that any vector space must satisfy if
all of the theory and constructs that
we've discovered are going to apply I'll
leave them on the screen here for anyone
who wants to pause and ponder but
basically it's just a checklist to make
sure that the notions of vector addition
and scalar multiplication do the things
that you'd expect them to do these
axioms are not so much fundamental rules
of nature as they are an interface
between you the mathematician
discovering results and other people who
might want to apply those results to new
sorts of vector spaces if for example
someone to find some crazy
type of vector space like the set of all
pie creatures with some definition of
adding and scaling pie creatures these
axioms are like a checklist of things
that they need to verify about their
definitions before they can start
applying the results of linear algebra
and you as the mathematician never have
to think about all the possible crazy
vector spaces people might define you
just have to prove your results in terms
of these axioms so anyone whose
definitions satisfy those axioms can
happily apply your results even if you
never thought about their situation
as a consequence you tend to phase all
of your results pretty abstractly which
is to say only in terms of these axioms
rather than centering on a specific type
of vector like arrows in space or
functions
for example this is why just about every
textbook you'll find will define linear
transformations in terms of additive 'ti
and scaling rather than talking about
grid lines remaining parallel and evenly
spaced even though the latter is more
intuitive and at least in my view more
helpful for first-time learners even if
it is specific to one situation so the
mathematicians answer to what our
vectors is to just ignore the question
in the modern theory the form that
vectors take doesn't really matter
Aeros lists of numbers functions pie
creatures really it can be anything so
long as there's some notion of adding
and scaling vectors that follows these
rules it's like asking what the number
three really is whenever it comes up
concretely it's in the context of some
triplet of things but in math it's
treated as an abstraction for all
possible Triplets of things and lets you
reason about all possible triplets using
a single idea same goes with vectors
which have many embodiments but math
abstracts them all into a single
intangible notion of a vector space
but as anyone watching this series knows
I think it's better to begin reasoning
about vectors in a concrete visualizable
setting like 2d space with arrows rooted
at the origin but as you learn more
linear algebra know that these tools
apply much more generally and that this
is the underlying reason why textbooks
and lectures tend to be phrased well
abstractly
so with that folks I think I'll call it
an into this essence of linear algebra
series if you've watched and understood
the videos I really do believe that you
have a solid foundation in the
underlying intuitions of linear algebra
this is not the same thing as learning
the full topic of course that's
something that can only really come from
working through problems but the
learning you do moving forward could be
substantially more efficient if you have
all the right intuitions in place
so have fun applying those intuitions
and best of luck with your future
learning
[Music]